to North America now where authorities
say at least 30 people have now died due
to the extreme weather that's sweeping
the U.S and Canada nearly 2 million
homes and businesses have suffered from
power outages and countless holiday
makers have found themselves stranded
Christmas day where progress was slow
and frustrating here in New York state
cars slipping and sliding in slow motion
plows on the roads trying to clear a
path through the snow but many are only
scratching the surface the state
Governor urging people to stay home I
can add overstate how dangerous the
conditions still are we need people to
stay off the roads yes one more day I
know it's Christmas I know how hard it
is you came off of a couple years of
being separated during the pandemic it's
heartbreaking
some of those who wanted to leave their
homes couldn't even get out the front
door
well that was a colossal waste of time
this is how far I made it out the snow
is so thick and heavy that
can't even get through it
snow has been piling up from Coast to
Coast with freezing winds sending
temperatures plunging well below zero
across the border in Canada Travelers
are also battling the elements so it's
going by train from Ottawa arrived at
the station to find their Journeys
canceled for some for luggage went back
into the taxi others though don't know
how to get home
unfortunately trains were canceled for
today so just trying to get back home
for the holidays now I'm waiting for a
cab to go to a hotel and stay there for
a day hopefully it's just a day and then
go back
across North America the Winter weather
has knocked out power leaving Millions
cold and in the dark
forecasters say the Deep Freeze will
stick around for Christmas before a
return to Karma conditions from Monday
or someone who's had a busy few days is
our next guest meteorologist Matthew
capucci in Washington D.C Matthew High
there good to see you it's it's quite
difficult to describe a storm of this
scale and intensity what's the latest on
its progress through Canada and the U.S
this room was a bomb Cyclone essentially
a little pressure system vacuuming in so
much air towards the middle there went
up and out and now it's sucking in more
cold air from behind which is why
temperatures over the century who has to
drop to minus 40 Celsius now the issue
even though it's pulled into Canada is
that the cool air is coming in the
backside which is pushing down Lake
Sperry in Ontario picking up moisture
from the lakes and deposing it as a form
as a very heavy snowfall in the vicinity
of Buffalo New York which is why 130
centimeters of snow have fallen again
very prolific snowfall totals of around
like 130 centimeters and a blizzard
condition is likely as well with gusts
you were 90 kilometers per hour
okay is there more bad weather to come
or is the worst behind us now
honest I think this is finally pulling
into
for us in the United States but the
other issue too is how wide the system
is about a 1600 kilometers wide which is
why Gusty winds are so prevalent and as
a result about 4 000 flights have been
canceled roughly 1.5 million people in
the US without power 30 people dead and
the issues for travel have just really
been cascading flight play so many folks
have been unable to travel for a
Christmas holiday and many other
holidays as well
Matthew I'm just interested to know your
point of view about the the causes of
this storm how much of this can we pin
on things like climate change
I think that's a really tough thing to
say so these sort of storms these middle
attitude Cyclones tend to feed off
something called barroclinicity or
essentially a change in temperature with
distance uh over a short kind of
distance at the the lower levels that's
something we tend to see near the Gulf
Stream or a warm current of water off
the Eastern Seaboard so we typically see
these things off the east coast of the
United States very rarely do we see them
over the Great Lakes especially in
December so to see something like this
is not necessarily tied to climate
change is more random but it's a rarity
nonetheless that said there are signs
that the jet stream the upper level
current up winds in the upper atmosphere
is becoming more a little bit wavy
thanks to climate change and that may be
something that may have been tied to the
development of this system so again kind
of very
spurious links but kind of tough to
connect but regardless of a sort of you
know if there was to be a connection it
would be that albeit unlike okay Matthew
capucci in Washington DC there Matthew
thanks very much
thank you